hello guys welcome to the chest for
tonight's lecture / class / stream so
today I'm my name is Darius I'm gonna
show some interesting and classical game
from the from the path played by Robert
James Fisher world champion and but
before we do that I just wanted to show
some two positions which will basically
describe the entire theme of what we're
gonna be talking today about and so this
is the position number one I want to
talk about it's called intro on animal
intro on and basically I want to discuss
today such strategical sort of aspect
such as you know feature as a very
strong night versus bad Bishop so in
this position this one of the example
positions of the basic equality made up
is not for any game in this position
white has a huge advantage and it's
based on first of all this verse from
night and this very bad Bishop and this
Bishop is very constricted like very
stressed race it doesn't can go really
can really go anywhere all of the black
pawns
apart from epsilon h7 are on the dark
squares which basically makes this piece
very defensive piece and can they can do
really much in the game and while this
knight on f5 has lots of possibilities
of maneuvering around regrew regrouping
py has possibility of regrouping pieces
and this knight can come here for
instance sorry not not only 5.2 d5 for
instance on the light squares King what
what can king go like this for instance
comes from good gets to d5 white can
basically be seven there are lots of
ideas here for white while black is
basically restricted to only defense so
for instance one possible move here for
white is to play rugby seven basically
putting some more pressure on black and
the black is for basically to just stay
in place and not do anything because
otherwise it will just drop money
multi-material
let's say rook a eight what can play the
King for instance and if the room comes
here to a two let's say the root beer
already wins the piece so black is
forced to basically different passively
here and white can just you know do to
be honest nearly whatever and can what
can win the game just you know by
proving pieces that's a 93 Knight 25
then King comes here just grabbing this
f6 points around this point getting it
so there are ideas like this and it's
all based the major thing is that this
based on this very story on a5 and very
bad Bishop on a fade encased in this
position let's say it was white player
birthplace this and this Bishop wasn't
dark or bishop but light square bishop
on e6 then it would cover is kind of
tight at night differ ratified it would
take either on d5 on a5 but with light
square bishop but the thing is that
direct curvature is basically restricted
by its own pawns and white white knife
has sort of free play and if you know
all around the board and it's a huge
advantage so this is what I'm gonna be
talking about today and also another
example of this of this before we
showing Fischer's game and one modern
example the same idea which is very
instructive as well so let me get to the
intro like second example which is this
position
second its disposition and here in this
position it's as you guys can see it's
very similar to the previous position
only difference is that it is light
square bishop and very weak dark squares
well this night only fires very strong
piece obviously and this bishop means it
is terrible like it's surrounded is
hitting its own pawns
it's basically forced to only defense in
case it's wide to play what can win and
basically I think two ways or like
possibly even more about like the the
easiest one of the two two moves out
consider is here is either King D six
working B six ball moves are looking
just crushing honor to be honest and why
because here this Bishop is forced to
defend all the points and can basically
attack any of white/blue pawns
and while this night can maneuver around
we can regroup let's say D three and
then go to c5 and hit this pawn and it's
very very difficult for black to face
the only possible possibly move is King
be 895 Bishop c8 but then slowly black
will run out of moves because it will
this domination of this night over this
Bishop is just like overwhelming so
having these two positions in mind I
wanted to discuss one of the five most
famous games played by Fisher Robert
James Fisher in 1959 I believe like it
was in tears oh no versus Julio Bob no
sorry that was 1962 it was against Julio
bol bachchan and in this game
fisher beautifully out out play his
opponent and employed those ideas a very
strong night versus very bad bishop and
it's sort of like a classic game that
basically everyone should know so let's
look at it and
what how Fischer outplayed his opponent
so this is this is it let me just make
sure yeah all right so this was a four
and in here you would well become played
see 593 d6 d4 state d4 Knight takes d4
96 Knight c3 a 69.95 3 which for sure
Fischer is to employ quite often he also
plays versed in Bishop c4 but H 3 as
well and here this is of course modern
Theory basically goes like e 5 there is
movie 5 e 6 GC is also possible 96 bla
bla chance choice is also possible but
it's a little bit like less accurate is
considered I think g4 and played Fisher
and right now as I think the main move
the best try for black is to play Queen
b6 I mean here trying to keep this knife
from before but Baba Bachchan played
night X t4 which is the beginning or
very flawed idea in general you're not
supposed to take on like train if you
are not forced to trade in try you
should if you if I wanted to trade nice
then Knight XE 6 BC SBCC's would be in
blacks favor and the wall attacking on
d4 is unnecessary impacts favor
so trading pieces like this doesn't
really make much sense but anyway Queen
b6 or is better move but Knight takes d4
it was the being of the fall idea that
the Baba John had in mind because it's
very forced a queen takes d4 and E 5 and
this is serious mistake does entire idea
simply because right now as you guys can
see this pawn structure this pawn on e4
comes through it was pawns d6 and e5 and
this d5 square suddenly becomes
available for white knight
we will see later in the game that this
was basically the beginning of all black
struggle in this game and this is why
black has lost this game and Fischer's
technique was by the way brilliant so
possibly here it was already better to
play something like h6 which which is
already very shaky for black but it was
already much better than thingy 5 simply
because it just doesn't give away like
square slide just like that but ok if 5
was played by Bob Cochin quindi free
logical just come retrieve the Queen
Bishop e7 g5 hitting the knight 97 we
should be free perfect and here
95 was played by buoyed by bol bachchan
it's not a good right move in my opinion
simply because this night its support is
supposed to sort of fight this night on
TC 3 this night it's supposed to fight
this knight on c3 so if this Knight is
definitely coming to d5 at some point
black should try to make some attempts
to make sure maybe that goes to b6 or
something like this rather than to c5
that's why I would rather consider
playing maybe here in solution b5 if
idea Bishop d7 Luke she may be denied b6
something like this
our position is definitely desert then
very shaky for black it was probably
better to play like this but anyway
below champion I see 522 Bishop e6 a
long castle short castle everything
normal
both sides are developing their pieces a
free rock c8 can be won and here was
here Bharata made major mistake again 97
and basically usually you're not
supposed to just come back with the
pieces unless they're attacked - and
like you know putting all the pieces on
the back rank like to go in backwards
usually you should go forward and he's
here but watch and decided to go
backwards maybe his idea was play Knight
b6
but like in white the first and then we
play Knight like the 95 it's not like
wasting time so therefore in here
if while bragger a plane at c5 you know
black should try to kind of like try to
create some kinks quiz' that either
simply be five which was much more all
occur at ninety four and this was way
more sensible rather than just coming by
ninety seven because here these there
are some hopes for let's say contour
play and if we trade the night that
salary is v square is not the you know
problem anymore so here for sure what
should be 95 with advantage but at least
not only for create some let's say
danger to the whites King you know this
I don't I thought maybe create some
danger to White's King so it's not so
clear not entirely clear however we've
correctly why it should be much better
anyway but what for instance night XE
for will be huge mistake suddenly
because right now why doesn't have
control over D Phi square anymore and
design doesn't come to d5 so it's
suddenly position gets really really
unclear and who knows what's going on so
coming back to this position can be one
Bob chaplains mistake 97 h4 we should be
five and now Bishop h3 was played by
Fisher and this very strong move because
the idea is that the only defender of
this d5 square is this Bishop so if we
trade that Bishop with this we've trade
was lights called bishops we can
basically occupy this defy score of the
night and then we will see basically
this night versus this bad Bishop only
seven will tell in the future that you
know like it will show it's kind of like
superiority in the future decided versus
this Bishop so but first we need to try
those bishops and here Baba channels
simply I've I've my pen didn't
understand what was going on and he
simply took on h3 so it was big big
mistake because like he Bob voluntarily
just gave up this Bishop rather than
well instead you should just keep it in
any case because for instance if you
played something like rugby it for
instance Ruby eight and here okay this
is basically trying to get out of this
diagonal because this bishop is very
strong is getting with this rook out of
there may be preparing before or
something like this and here if white
wanted to take only six the F takes is
six and suddenly this d5 square is not
anymore available to this night because
Poland despondently six and pawn on e6
basically covers d5 square and opens all
after F this is also black hits on f3 so
it's not so clear anymore so this was I
think correct way to react to Bishop h3
of course what doesn't have to take on
e6 and correct movies possibly just 95
and if not takes d5 25 like what is is
still huge advantage but the differences
the list here this knight on d5 is not
dominating over this Bishop only 7 so
here of course black is in big big
trouble still both but you know maybe
Knight be some chance and if Queen comes
by Knight c4 if Bishop takes b6 well at
least of course position is still bad
because it pushed myself is terrible is
non dominant over this Knight by design
on d5 and also different colorations
maybe create some chances in long run
perspective that black and maybe escape
for a draw by trading or visiting some
leaving only lights different color
bishops and trying to make a drawing
different color bishop endgame even like
if it's bone down or something like that
so this was correct defense but after we
shove h3 which is definitely a mistake
suddenly the night comes to the fire
completely unopposed so here played
netball champlain 96 I'll you at night C
for but obviously right now we should
take b6 I'm not sure whether it was
really anything better because I was 95
grams
either way to d5 so at least he managed
to trade some pieces but 95 right now
and Queen d8 and as you we finally got
to the position where basically what I
wanted to talk about how I got to this
position and what are basically the main
ideas how to proceed from here with
white because the way Fischer won this
game is very very instructive first of
all I wanted to discuss whether white
can maybe grab the pawn on d6 so
basically it's sort of like when I was a
kid I remember I will I was curious sort
of whether white was maybe white can
just traded bishop on e7 and take on d6
because 90 xe7 who in seven quintet is
it seems like we are getting the pawn
and this approach is wrong for topple
for two reasons first of all it
basically fails tactically in this
position because a black player just
rook f d8 suddenly and the black is
winning because of the back rank issues
that the world is having we take several
tasty one mate so this is sort of a trap
that Bob Tom had in mind definitely but
all I wanna talk but I wanted to talk
about this white this 97 is wrong not
only tactically because of Queen 6 room
d8 but also why is it wrong to take this
night totally take this pawn
even considering that there is no rock
to rock da by let's say only Quintin
0:26 basically this Knight is worth much
more than a pound
didn't just grab in the pond what can
achieve much more by just keeping it but
no by noon grabbing his phone but by
keeping it on design 95 and keeps booge
buh-booge 27 and by creating a King side
attack on the blacks King and I said
what Fisher did exactly like that
f4 he played for opening the F file
attack hidden in the center and opening
explained on the King side open goes for
the first rank for the room maybe rock
every would be possible something like
this so Queen tags on the for Queen
takes the 427 hitting the rock and right
now again
Queen a5 this is what Fisher didn't
remove because even end games are here
like with the same and defamatory or
okay first of all quinny-quinn a five a
night 87 just wins so but even if Queen
a5 it takes the five was also different
it's like overwhelming but here there's
a solution trig of 97 so but the most
important thing is that he doesn't take
only seven he doesn't take this pawn
simply because suddenly there this could
be Roxy form of and suddenly it killing
is getting really messy suddenly what
has week pawn on e4 and the what has
defend and it can get really really
unclear here what can black connects K
for a draw the 0 if free definitely
you're defending the pawn but suddenly
f5 is maybe possible
you know guys it's like very very
unclear position like this is looking
very very messy unlike this position
where basically it's clear and obvious
that what is definitely winning here
simply because design um defies dominate
over this Bishop on e7 so it's just not
worth it Justin worth it the white can
really grab the point was just not worth
it the relative to what possibilities
what happened is between the half white
has in this game so this guy played
pogchamp late cd8 rugae free hit in the
pawn queen a7 brooks III and the rest is
basically just perfect
technique by Fischer and like I just
want to point out a few things here
while showing the game because it's very
instructive how a Fischer was not even
rushing to take this point 24:27 Queen
f3 Queenie six rooks e7 hitting entering
the seventh ranked group the e8 neither
for hit in the Queen Queen e5 roopd five
already Queens has to go like to a child
which is awful obviously and suddenly of
course there are many moves the do it
there's h5 when interests a rook SL
hitting the polyneices Queen f3 could be
winning as well
where could it be she is not so clear
but like there are many many moves that
when Roxy six as well as possible simply
coming back there's Reuben play 95 back
also possible any basically that you
want but what I really liked officials
approach here because he just underlines
this kind of bad fate of this Bishop
died refurbish of the blackest and if in
such positions basically are surgically
winning is very good good
often times to tie just remove like l3
in case any come any complications
happened display some such moves like if
a free just to make a space for your
king in K in any case that position
opens up and there may be some you know
tactical ideas of the back rank just to
avoid any sort of ideas like this just
play a free and BFF peace of mind so h6
was played by Bob Beauchamp and but this
already tried to activate the Queen but
this on the other hand the weekends the
king so right now
Fischer simply goes after his opponents
king and mates so that's here let's see
how it finished judaize h6 Quinta h6 h5
opening the King side Bishop g5 h 2x g6
point hg 6 and queen bee free very
strong move basically as the off as the
f7 pawn is not there anymore this
diagonal is open and this creates
tactical ideas of this diagonal of this
cover check Luke takes the photo happen
in the game and right now
rookie five also which if I was possible
because I was possible this is what
maybe it was was well well Ruby files
very strong and it just made so King f8
because otherwise it is lost rook takes
e8 King takes II actually discover the
game and simply because there is there
made fall in few moves because after
King takes yet
[Music]
after King takes II hold on a second
after King takes yet here Queenie six
follows and after King Theodore squeeze
he had made and after King evaders Queen
a Vedic wish of the 8:28 mate so this is
how the game ended and what's really
important from this game - what to take
out is that this identifies three
powerful piece and it's not worth at
just a pawn is worth much more it
basically creates such paralysis over
black's pieces that what can do nearly
anything and black cannot to react to
this and what can just grab multiple
pawns by just having this night there
and by by the fact that black pieces are
so constructed black-white can just
create much again get much more than
just a pawn a by trading this 90-87 like
here for instance you just see the
difference like this position the safety
pin on a jade will or would have been if
not none after we take this pot this
night it this bishop of this night and
suddenly position gets really messy so
just work this night on the five such
powerful lines worth much more than just
a pawn so it this is the most most
important my opinion intake from i mean
like you know from this game by Fisher
and I will also to show a modern example
of the same idea that the fish are
employed and like what I'm talking
this night a powerful night over this
very bad bishop and this happened
actually very lately by my team mate
from proaches league Gregorio parent
will ever match against China pandas
which was unfortunately we lost but but
grigory played beautiful game against
Xiao Jun and like it's very instructive
how what he did how he did it and I
really I was really impressed by this
game remember so let's kind of look into
this game because it's very instructive
so lets me up and pull out this
grigory's game one second here alright
so he played against now Jun on March
4th
so basically like 10 days ago so mr.
Knight a little bit different than
Fisher style before but it doesn't it
didn't kind of prevent the grigory from
getting like such a great position so 93
f6 g3 be 64 we got some Queens in Queens
Indian defense chef Jacoby shall be
seven castle castle all good all theory
94 Bishop d2 all theory the six mappings
a little bit inaccurate no occurrence
from from theoretical standpoint Bishop
FCS as far as I know is the best move
however this is relatively playable as
well d5 first remove I'm a peon
basically game in the space if you guys
looked at my previous lecture about the
night there was the most important sort
of like starts with logical ideas
basically
Center along those ideas and the the
basically grigory text over the center
here
now it takes the two night XD to e5 and
suddenly if for and do you guys can see
a common field here I think it you do
because it special in seven suddenly
it's a little bit uncomfortable it's
like hitting its own pawns it's hitting
its own pawns
we should let's say Bishop to d6 and if
he goes to f6 all those pawns based are
in the way of this Bishop so it's hard
to improve it and it basically the
source of all the problems of blackface
later in the game so 97 happened the
game we need to normal move g6 Bishop h3
al you guys remember Fischer played very
similar move in the game
Bishop h3 with the bishop on e6 right
now a grigory play Bishop h3 and there
is no Bishop on this diagonal yet so we
can't trade it yet
this is why score bishops but Bishop on
b7 has because of the strong central
White has has no way of coming back to
the game rather than Bishop c8 and after
if he comes to see the basically be
traded for this Bishop and this stuff is
definitely in white favor because this
leaves Bishop completely out like it
would be only piece of only be show that
black hat and if we even then trade
mention trade nights then this Bishop
will even worse because of the all the
lights control of the light over the
light squares that white will have and
let's see how I put him in the game shop
see it before h5
a 4 and right now Rosen made major
mistake mapping played h4 which is
basically completely unnecessary in my
opinion because if this rockin if the
Black team castle yet this rule rope on
would be on a jet if there was no castle
on the King side this would be on h8
and maybe it will be some let's say
pressure on the H file for this Bishop
but right now it's just kind of like
pushing pawn forward and just trading it
for the h4 point for this
you know H for a poem for each tuple
after hg hg so it doesn't really change
anything in the position so it's kind of
like waste of time without the rookin I
trade so I don't really see world Watts
was John's idea here but in mapping the
best move here was a five and on the
contrary with why will black try to
cream controverted the c5 scholarship it
takes a five Rob takes a five and then
I'd see five maybe of course what the
next I will never get there easily
because what can play might be phrase
the white is slightly better here but
position is you know way more balanced
at least black already managed to trade
some pawns here and disrupt the pawn
structure that white has so h4 happened
the game the which was a mistake and now
a five obviously
hdhdhd free doesn't as I said doesn't
really change anything also F takes G
free was worth attention but again no
need for that I've my opinion so it
takes just g3 Knight f6
one way or another black will have to
play this move sooner or later
simply because otherwise how will black
play with you know his pieces there is
no basically easy way to develop them
and let's say King g7 just you know is
what could another Kingi Taurua gauge I
drew page one doesn't really change
anything either analysis will be coming
at some point so Knight f6 happened
right now be shopped Excel quintic c8
Kim G - Kim G 700 page 127 all normal
moves and right now I really like the
move that Gregory played i6 the idea
behind this move is that it fixes the
structure on the Queen side and this
pollen a7 is suddenly becoming a
weakness and this would this pollinate
six and the backend d5 square this night
came it can come to b5 and basically hit
this pawn or a 7 and the rest rate this
roof on a yet to solve simply just only
defending this pawn a7 so in case of the
rock trades on H fallacy with you
because row page file is open so let's
say
it can happen that suddenly why will pay
row gauge 3 row gauge 1 and then what
black we want to trade okay Jade the for
instance I'll just make some random
moves here just to show what I'm what
I'm trying to say let's say if black
plays some move like rook g8 for
instance white plays this some random
move rook h1s nu k Jade because the game
dangerous suddenly make it really really
ugly for for black simply because I'd be
fine and is there difficulties
difficulties with this pawn and see all
because white pawn put despondently six
which creates huge problems of course
right now in this example black has quit
yet which interview this his this pawn
so what should prepare it somehow better
but like as an idea it gets really
really tricky for bag of disappointing
as general reform so it's always good to
play this move a six and the dodging ray
I think if he realized all the dangers
in his positions that's why he tried to
read in the center by undermining what
center of c6 quindi free rook c8 detect
c6 quintile c6 all good - okay c1 rook
e8 I mean if you if you have to play
rook e8 here and bake me because it is
number 5 you know sort of fred is being
so strong it means it's just not a good
position and as you guys can see after
c6 here plate detects c6 queen takes c6
progressive on suddenly we have very
similar structure to what was in the
game of Fisher versus Bob watch on this
knight on d5 the square of d5
is the back end again and mission
service is really bad and if we can get
the nightly traded one pair of nights
and get this Knight to d5 if we can just
make it both signs disappear from the
board and I comes to defines basically
exactly the same thing would happen in
the future as game so this would be
perfect idea perfect plan for for
grigory in my opinion so let's see what
he was doing he planar definitely which
I'm not sure whether it was the best
move here because on your hand people
who just plain I have one a night if we
need d5 is a very powerful idea that is
actually typical because in lot of
Sicilians it happens
very often eight of 195 so if he play
this he would have had like huge advance
after ID five I'm not entirely convinced
how big his advantages but still an
advantage definitely 27 simply because
right now instead of d5 score he has c6
square + b5 score is still vacant for
this night so if he can bring this night
here it's still definitely a big
advantage but it would be having better
if he had also underscored d5 so it's
debatable in mapping we were playing out
of one but it was his choice so let's
see what happens and the freer okay Jade
b5 okay he he he decides to have only be
5 so only in c6 square for his pieces
which is also definitely in now if you
can somehow exploit the c6 square so
will be great so locate Rodrick h1 rook
c8 logical basically trying to control
the the C file and there was it was
there are some issues with King edge 1
simply because there was will be rook
age 8 or something like this kingi wall
and queen h3 and there are some
certainly huge issues of the h5 that's
why he was forced to take of Queen each
one made basically it's just stuff oh I
think so rook each one was sort of
forced move rook c8 and this was a good
try by Zhao Jun simply because right now
black controls the C file that's why
wife has to get back rook good and get
the route back to the C file somehow in
order to fight for this file and that
black doesn't get a counter play because
the back end get Connor play of Queen's
rook suffice analyst poem if I couldn't
become a weakness that's why I really
like the next move Queenie Friedrich or
Gregory play because he frightens Queen
h6 mate and also there is strategical
sorry idea not rugby one but Roxy one
and trying to trade those rooks and as I
said in the beginning or like coming
back to the intro positions in both
positions they were basically were night
versus the just versus Queen universe
the bishop and inverse positions that
was completely dominant piece and this
is what is white aiming for here if
white can trade all the pieces and leave
a
the heavy piece is nicknamed the rookin
queen and leave just night versus the
bishop wise position be certainly
winning simply because this bishop is so
constricted still by its own pawns plus
there are another guide pawns Darkspore
on B 6 and a 7 which still remains a
weakness so right now he had like.he he
had possibility play Bishop f6 which was
I think much better defense than what he
did in the game but he packing g8 which
is very difficult it was also rapid
gains is difficult ly difficult to gauge
what to do because if any luck suffice
is the loss is losing because the
finishing is just made you Queen I said
next so he could do react somehow and
basically in it was hard decision but
Bishop f6 or King g8qe is more natural
because he was just growing out of the
check on h6 and right now I really
really like
grigory's move because the rock c1 and
we're now we are trading these pieces
those rocks and all the active player
black might have had is basically gone
so he became g7 and now Rock c6 and the
black white rook occupies the c6 square
and this is basically nearly game of
rogue a jet hitting on a teenage free so
just 9g want to just make sure that we
don't get mated we shove DEA and the his
technique was was also really nice Queen
f3
shove DN Queen e2 g5 Queen f3 back move
around a little bit Quincy to of course
now draw Rou Andrew gage 5 trying to f5
or something not very sure what it does
do gauge 8 Roxy was really good move
because right now a black monster why he
wants to play Queen c6 even sometimes so
rocky Jade Brooke a8 very strong move
hitting on a 7 for maybe creates a
thread of Quincy's right now I know if
we want to trade Queens so around jump
layup c7 and the idea is the droop a7
may not happen so clear I don't really
get why he can take pawn
also probably a 7 wins but Mia
definitely should be winning as well but
the thing is it doesn't even have to do
this the idea is a queen
Quinn Texas teenager in Quincy six is
just so dominating that he there is not
even necessity at this point I seven
like this it is winning yes but there is
no even necessity for that because Luca
takes a type king Texas Jake wins Quincy
six is just completely winning because
if we trade Queens suddenly this score
on D Phi becomes vac and again that can
come here this is a good thing about
neither you can just jump around all
those squares what Bishop is basically
considered only fairly two squares on
the board so yeah and also be Texas is
possible and we've idea of coming with
Dez night to be five let's see three and
ninety five so it's also possible
depending what you like more both are
winning
so Quincy Quincy Acy didn't want to try
twins but there is no way basically that
he can come survive this because Quinn
v8 fan he has to trade Queens we take
speed rook Bishop BA and right now this
is just brilliant as you guys can see
over the next couple of notes this night
simply is headed towards the c6 square
and black cannot do anything about it
and Astakhov statistics then Bishop
Bishop on PN will be will either have to
move to c7 because it will be lost and
the night of night X a7 or King will
have to come to support this Bishop but
then it will be both pieces would be
forced to defend on the Kings side on
the Queen side I mean while Y will be
able to open the Kings side and just win
the game on the King side and this is
what having the game is very instructive
92 here we go King g7 Knight c3 that's
what I mean King of 693 King g8 I before
King G 7
knight c6 Knight came to c6 and this is
we just came over this again dominant
night versus the very bad bishop forced
to defend this pawn on a server so King
c7 and right now just you know opening
the King King side f4 and this this jazz
game over just
completely because white has all the
moves on the kingside who just you know
can go of the king here and it's just
winning just completely winning
basically it's like what is playing with
just soul king versus all the pawns and
there is nothing that black can do here
because of the this King is forced to
defend this bishop and this bishop sorry
the bishop is forced to defend this pawn
so it's complete paralysis basically so
in the game happened f6 and right now
grigor grigor a plate of five and he's
open to got a 5 in case of g5 of course
we cannot never pledge filled with g4
because suddenly could be a draw still
are some chances because the spawns are
so weak there could be some choices for
wind to it but basically just king of
free this is what I was saying in your
free is just much stronger and kimchi
for King Ashraf King Jesus just kinked
the white king is coming to the blacks
camp and just collect on f6 cogs on g5
promote all the pawns because this is
still not moving anywhere it's not going
anywhere so giant I type took Gregory
took King c8g for King c7 and right now
he could have just played anything but
the very simple solution was actually
right now to take because it just can't
expiain g5 and basically the pawns the
King is too far of the Kings I'll pass
on the King side and
[Music]
that's how the game is concluded
basically here is Arjun resigned so it
was a perfect game by grigory and we we
we still we were still fighting then
against China Panos in purchase league
but eventually lost them the entire
match but this game was really very
beautiful instructive and it goes along
with the theme that was held at the of
the powerful and dominant night versus
the very bad Bishop and the same thing
happened in the Fisher's gained same
thing happened here so it just says that
in certain positions when the knight can
dominate over the bishop you should try
to exploit that and for our advantage
and just make sure that you don't trade
this bishop for just a pawn because very
likely will be more of much more than
just a pawn
for instance here it was all equal
material it's all equal material but
because of the paralysis that this night
causes for blacks pieces like for
instance if there was no 56 square the
spawn would be here on the 7-pole shall
be completely different because the dial
on does not wouldn't get to see six
because pawn on the seven would be by
him covering six the c6 square and then
this Bishop can activate software on c5
somehow but in this point position 496
is just just just waiting for white so I
thought it was instructive and that's
all I have for today on this thing so it
will be it for today and thank you guys
and until next time